scott's like we're going for baby number
four is that serious i want to know
um say what now i don't know
i'm just like living life in a new
trailer for the upcoming season 19
premiere of keeping up with the
kardashians
kim straight up confronts her big sis
courtney about
this comment that scott apparently made
scott's like we're going for baby number
four
was that serious i want to know that's
when someone off camera
asks this are you pregnant
of course the clip ends before court can
reply
but it seems like there could be a
little something something going on
between the amicable x's
tune in because you never know what's
going to happen just to recap
court and scott called it quits in 2015
after almost a decade of dating
then scott dated sofia richie for about
three years but they split in may
and lately he's been spending lots of
time with the mama of their three kids
back in june
court was spotted wearing her ex's
flannel shirt on a family vacate to
wyoming
which got fans speculating that the two
could be back on
of course courtney and scott share 10
year old son mason eight-year-old
daughter penelope and a five-year-old
son
reign and they could pretty much write
the how-to guide on how to successfully
raise kids with your ex
it was definitely a process back in 2019
scott told et the secret to co-parenting
like a boss
i think you just gotta figure out really
what's important to you at the end of
the day
you just want to be happy you want to be
content you want to be comfortable
life is a challenge and if you work at
what you want
you can get it but it takes hard work
simple as that
you can easily live less of a life
without working as hard and court's
younger sister chloe
gave them mad props too it's hard work
for all parties
i think they're doing amazing and i
think everyone has to handle their
co-parenting situation in their own
style but
my mom and my dad were like that it took
them years but my dad would come over
once a week for family dinners and would
play golf with my stepdad and
so we come from a family where we
believe in that and you share
children with people and that's how it
should be and
love is love and i'm so proud of them
and i'm so proud of them promoting that
and hopefully
you know inspiring other people that
it's a beautiful thing to get along
with each other and for your kids to see
[Music]
that